oh my god that's crazy
this is soup and I'm here for it I'm
barrel I produce a series called around
the world where I take one topic and
look at different iterations of it
around the world this week I'm looking
at soup we're a few months into
quarantine and I need about all the
comfort I can get of course there are
the classics you've got French onion
soup New England clam chowder minestrone
to name a few but I want to learn about
something new right now so I talked to
seven people in seven countries to learn
about some of the more surprising soups
that people make around the world this
is the soup episode in making this
episode I decided two things one I'm not
doing canned or packaged soup that is a
whole other episode and if you want that
one let me know
and two I'm looking for soups that make
me do a double-take
okay so let's begin the a commute is a
New Orleans noodle soup it cares ain't
no sigh hey Tina - no lovin teeny
Omnicon here ah ha ha ah - Milania start
a new day and I'm so hello yep why
Muhammad city Pappy honey come home from
the subterranean Makka pakka teja me
Sarah told you know his journey areas
gonna be ultimate a knockout Valley
banditos ah
I mean bhai Marilyn's belugas macoco
mozilla sahib little sir bhai KO metalli
may may pinto sunic assume bread omar
caldo so sopes al desayuno in colombia
la Chango APPA Mucha gente super exotic
on oh poor case una so pilot hey kiera
tanto en amore cos if we did do ID
kamidana who yes she offer to nephew
more mum
in cattle mooing what my name me when
they mated through new occasioning the
wharf weird when he may work at you type
Island to make a shank for you so a pun
Taiwan you owe me a chunk or you should
not I jump targets I eat buy it all down
by quite tightly outside I just think
you know me I'm quite a Jaguar Joe call
us which I'm quite happy because you're
not hiding
[Music]
as for me I'm to be making a soup that
uses two ingredients that I think a lot
of us find comfort in beer and cheese so
I'm gonna be making Wisconsin beer and
cheese soup cut a fun fact my dad and
sister both went to university in
Wisconsin go Rodgers but for me I don't
know it just sounds really good soup yes
beer yes jeez yes I don't know all right
let's do it
I'm gonna start prepping these
ingredients the first soup I loved
because it's made for a very particular
group of people in Japan so far so good
suchan Coonabarabran Oishi really
speciality you know the circular mini
nothing
watashi wa moto cuatro menos de Matos
Changu senator scott script is a mess a
lot more retuning
Aramis choco lava sentence on tanto para
la rambla de Moda para una comida de
rosario irritated who are the characters
no super not an example the ideal
irritated Freeman was also from now
Seattle to discuss in Bali you a little
assist me can optimally Ron nice
criminology archenemies Melanie no champ
or Die scuse me I have the beginning of
my stock everything is going nicely the
ingredients are pretty easy to work with
which brings me to my next soup the
ingredients in this one are a little
more elevated and the soup is
surprisingly expensive foods English
analogous to our my father knew me and
so how is she
so thorough and Sam Vegas Lea [ __ ]
Gina I think it's only a family go
conquer to run current so on the one you
don't wait for such a baby food so you
can't see without someone inquire not to
a dead halt or I fire you there's a so
under the balls just this year cooling
current haven't agri-food charge any
minutes to make a pinky the Honjo pink
area charging the you unpackage it yeah
mojo ang
was an evolving then the lutheran the
gentleman boy who the sons of your own
medicine
a punk rocker media a challenging genome
ian hunter danger zone called out
me in Kandahar or mrs. King to have
enjoyed our day at a long time I have a
boundary at all thirds of the media
Commons and once and a guy who eats at
you get back to you Hong Kong Xin Zang
with tidy LA because Chang was and yo
without poses are making online effect
on tawa masala and anything else you
taught me that soup is one of those
dishes where I think you can get away
with a lot
you don't need to be a great chef and
you can use almost any ingredient
including some that try as you might you
can find at a supermarket they come in
comas Raymond even if lovely young
Muslim Ecosse Edie McCoy is Paris
Kakaako I heard it was a blood sample
squad this body balances our house desde
la la Saguna Gunilla elena lavas parent
saliva present occasionally foxy Edina
Badman and ten minutes 20 minutes too
big
neguin Peron Segundo malanga Sheila nice
Neela
the Nalini tsunami man down demo in
Holland in detention is Priscilla Hollow
and Amina chick in Arizona
yum yum soup nian but Ellen hollow will
enlasa
help and Mahalo and mundane odors in
Alamo
mean asana it'll also be pneumococci a
picto coyoacán epical la la pasión
[Music]
soup is simmering nicely not much to
report on over here but it's a great
segue into the next soup which has been
simmering for quite some time
I'm not from Lyon and I'm super glad I
have Lockheed Martin what
c-chief happy Apple took one large
American employer to keep - I'm not
someone who need a tapa hub from - not
upon convenient home hub been to one a
thumbnail veloute found online but an
infinite couple hoodie keep console even
colleague who could pour me a power to
pull a brief on chopped and Nina
losartan chopped a mohandro Ihaka the
kid soon even Maya lager talk month to
Kampala car but you burned my you didn't
papa so [ __ ] off he loved China the soup
with your new home lobotomy hung Neptune
no soul looks in like a pack of the
cogniser in hubcap ah sigh top which I
facili
of all our new animated 9m to plot one
from one corner and avatar of man item
soup coming up - Milania come come come
come waka pay up okay I'm waiting for
butter to melt and then I'm gonna be
adding some flour a lot of
[Music]
I'm gonna try this hmm you can taste the
beer it's good okay so the next Duke
that I chose I thought was very fitting
because I'm making a beer and cheese
soup and this is a type of soup that you
would want the morning after a lot of
beer huh Hangul is very common in New
Orleans I got that hangover cure for you
I'm chef Linda Greene they called me the
Aquaman lady people find me at festivals
a lot of them call me and I make them
for the a commune is good for you it's
good for the soul
yeah Camille was classified as a poor
man dish it was a leftover dish you take
that leftover chicken you know ropes if
you have a rolls on Sunday come on we
bout to make some yeah Camille with this
it is Chinese an african-american
Chinese you know main is noodles
african-american we put out spices and
you heard and we elevated them it
consists of boneless chuck roast green
onions a heartburn age but it's really
about that flavor that's what it's about
when yo man hits the tongue it goes to
the brain
and then it comes back to the tongue and
tell me more I just love what I do I
love cooking I love cooking okay best
part
cheese feels pretty good to me
[Music]
so the next soup that we're gonna talk
about doesn't need spoons and that is so
cool
[Music]
freakin claw claw meaning washio buffet
be wait man come upon you immediately
I taught me every in a kolache the gana
mana me you mean akane casa que je
Minetti
like I know mean John B Cooney I mean I
met Li pona when I can deal in Iolani
[Music]
man your pet money back come on Ibaka
what's your Guardia kana fame or Maloney
okay food to a Madonna supply a more
[ __ ] to Sabbath low spices can be come
anybody on chose makhani hanya em now
who feign a photo oh no one way for free
forever tasty one way in waukesha
Muhammad is dead GOP Rococo Nene's year
but the enjoy ban difference it's more
free wanna okay I kept in wedlock way my
me for your life tragedy
okay hot bath kya hoga wooden when you
go for every weekend mo cry
G what weekend
coming near the end the six fabulous the
soup tastes so good okay this leads me
to my last soup and I love this one
because it flies in the face of when I
was told you are supposed to eat soup
which I intend no entiendes over the
toilet strong head okay caki on
autopilot
Kelly pungen will prepare amis Vika
medium Oh Marcel Arango Bo en la Calera
circa bogota colombia the Chiang Mai
Asuna so Park is a toma el desayuno
small mente is de la Sona kundi Royal
Assent
Colombia avoid viendo phenomena Savoy
Jacobi sona la cebolla larga cilantro it
wondersteam Fucci ona Oregano's la leche
Sal ich Wando esta bien Caliente vamos a
cocinar adentro el caldo de leche a los
huevos entonces de los ingrediente de la
changuk Raquel mess important des la
leche
eskimo Tommy Lomas curioso Kelly Chang
was a coma caliente SAV Mohsen katas
angwa El Callao y loca Samos con la
Johannes poner la encima para que se
mohei con la SOPA
Y termina mozcon my cilantro picado caso
campesino y también un poco ESO a larga
pica a Salah sorry ah leche racino Tonya
sorry Elena
Lara LuAnn Sepultura Lila changwu
croquets cantar El Campo Swiss una
storia el campo en esta record Mentos
Eskimo Lamas plato los recursos vesicles
el campesino and blood one of my
favorite things about this soup is that
the garnish is popcorn okay
I love this you taste the hops of the
beer but then you taste the cheese and
the popcorn is really good
Hannes loop this loop has everything
including cholesterol so what's my take
away
first off soup is way more interesting
than we give it credit for
it's a fabulous expression of flavors
and you can get really creative but soup
is also comfort and I think the people
who make it for you know that and I feel
like when we travel soup is probably the
first thing that we should be tasting
because we'll get a sense of what home
means wherever we are warming came off a
mocha body Balu began egg on a new stock
Safina no means no engineer linguini
gonna be peace moon told the quotient on
controller current residence in Madrid
papa
jihwan I don't even have the rotator
sigamani tamashii well-being pain relief
our domain gummy Luqman ganga Wang hua
lu han sample the much we can do Lu
defeat or by level my demoting - I began
a business I mean friend young a bunion
melaka maybe we can say la casilla Han
otineru ano campano
you know
Sonia Mumma Ballack Ballack shillitoe la
posada matenda no Sakana
de caso Enrico Mia's a potent a son
Kamiya's kalenna's como Eric um Plateau
sobre todo para compartir para compartir
em familia por lo mismo entonces siempre
que algo changhua eskimo pequeño man I
hate you no tiene con su familia I love
my cereal well not go to your world
about I'll miss it and I love the people
that come and enjoy my who I love that
[Music]
important I dunno what a prick - IRISA
given such anomalies
think okinawa serial innocent American
Association
[Music]